commission president ursula fonda lyon
will make her first state of the
european union address
meps will question her on the challenges
facing the eu
including the kovit 19 pandemic the
economic recovery and the climate crisis
in order to finance the 750 billion euro
recovery plan
the eu needs to raise more revenue
without burdening taxpayers
meps will vote on backing new sources of
revenue for the eu
including levies on unrecycled plastic
waste technology giants
and financial transactions some
eu regions still rely on polluting
fossil fuels like
coal parliament will set its position on
the just transition fund
which will help businesses industries
and workers make the change to a carbon
neutral economy
while the eu's civil protection
mechanism and rescue have successfully
supported member states through natural
disasters and emergencies
the kovit-19 crisis exposed their
limitations
parliament will set its position on more
equipment and resources
to better respond to future crises
the kovid 19 pandemic highlighted the
problem of shortages of some medicines
and medical equipment
parliament will discuss solutions like
returning drug production to the eu
creating a pan-european emergency
stockpile and promoting better
coordination between member states
you